welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Erin Jareau professor of film studies
and East Asian languages and
literature's at Yale University
professor Jareau teaches courses in
Japanese cinema and popular culture film
studies and film genre as well as
seminars on Japanese film and cultural
theory he has published numerous
articles and books in English Japanese
and other languages on such topics as
Japanese early cinema film theory
contemporary directors genre censorship
and cinematic representations of
minorities today we talk with him about
the history of Japanese film theory
welcome professor Jerrod uh-huh thank
you very much for having me
so you are in the process of writing a
book on the history of Japanese film
theory yes what led you to undertake
that endeavor well I think it's a rather
esoteric topic usually when I try to
explain it to people they kind of
scratch their heads at first
uh-huh especially for people not
familiar with film studies as a whole
they wonder what is film theory well in
some ways it's it's the most basic
question about well what is cinema what
defines cinema in comparison to the
other arts for instance those were some
of the very basic questions asked in
film theory at the beginning I has
progressed beyond that so for instance
later on questions of well does cinema
have its own language is cinema a
language how does cinema transmit
meaning how does meaning or
signification occur within cinema so
there are many many many different very
fundamental questions about cinema much
of the questions have evolved around for
instance the issue of modernity
if cinema is a modern medium what does
cinema tell us about modernity
what does modernity tell us about cinema
and unfortunately while in film studies
you know film theory is obviously one of
the central aspects of the discipline
when you open a book giving you a you
know the history of film theory or some
of the anthologies of the great writers
in film theory you never find anyone
who's not an American or European okay
that might be because no one else wrote
about it but it's not the case I mean
especially when you look at Japan Japan
has a very long history in fact there
were people who were writing books about
cinema from a very philosophical or
theoretical perspective even before they
were doing it in Europe so cinema has
really have has had a very very vibrant
history in Japan that has been
accompanied by a theoretical endeavor
but that history has never been told and
that's where you come that's right yes
when did Japan start doing cinema when
do they begin making films well in
general most people date cinema to 1895
which is when you had the first public
performance of a projected film and that
occurred in France with the Lumiere
brothers and what was interesting about
the Lumiere brothers is that they
actually developed a camera that could
also be a projector Wow
and they sent cameramen around the world
because then they could film things and
then project them and so as early as
1896 97-98 you already have people in
Japan projecting films so in some ways
film history begins in Japan at that
time but that was mostly foreign
cameramen then it's really past the year
1900 that you start seeing more Japanese
but especially the film industry in
Japan really really gets going around
1907 1908 but it's in 1914 that you
already have a wonderful book written by
this fellow named Juan de Asano sky 430
pages about cinema a lot of it's about
the technical aspects but part of it is
also he's really interested in how
cinema
is defining this new thing called
modernity mm-hmm
it's a really fascinating work and it's
before most of what was most of what is
canonized as like the first books on
film theory in the West okay and so what
will some of the issues be that you'll
tackle in your book well one of the
issues is this whole problem about the
kind of division that has been created
in the history of film theory about how
it is been concentrated on the West as
if in some ways only the West does film
theory right now that's simply not a
problem with the West in some ways that
has also been something that Japanese
thinkers have for one reason or another
recognized so even when you open books
in Japan about the history of film
theory you don't find Japanese names
continue why do you think that is well a
part of it is that even though of course
Japan was never colonized by the West
even though you could talk a little bit
about what the occupation after World
War two really meant nonetheless Japan
wasn't is any kind of neo-colonial
perspective in that especially as Japan
opened up to the West Western knowledge
was considered superior to Japanese
knowledge and you have many
intellectuals not only in film but in
many fields who for one reason or
another are always experiencing a kind
of inferiority complex that somehow what
we are doing in intellectual endeavor is
never quite enough to equal what the
West is doing and that actually was one
reason that Japanese film theory is
actually quite interesting quite
different because you have these people
who are actually writing extremely
brilliant things about cinema in fact
broaching certain ideas before people in
the West are approaching those ideas but
they're always doing it with the
consciousness that what they're doing is
not going to be recognized by the
West and it's that kind of complex in
the multiple senses of that term is
because a very complex but it's also a
kind of like inferiority complex
that has led Japanese film theory to
always be an investigation of theory as
well it's a kind of meta level to it
which I think has made it a very very
interesting theory especially today
because as film has essentially
disappeared it's now the digital age
films are no longer made on celluloid
that has created a crisis for film
studies well because you know so much of
our discipline has been centered around
this photographic process okay of
celluloid with an emulsion receiving
light and in some ways becoming an
imprint of reality but now things are
made undal to the point that sometimes
you can see images which look real but
we're completely made inside the
computer right
that's just one of the many examples of
the problems that the digital has
created so in some ways film studies is
rethinking its discipline as well as
rethinking its history and actually part
of that process is rethinking film
theory there is actually an organization
a worldwide organization called the
permanent seminar on the histories of
film theories which is actively looking
at these film theories that have been
ignored up until now in fact starting
today the next session of the permanent
seminar is going to be having a
conference at Yale oh great over the
next couple days and I'll be
participating just a little bit there
and will you be talking about jab you
know things going on in Japan I will be
obnoxious and insist on okay um you know
I am curious you are a westerner okay
and you're writing in this book about
you know the history of Japanese film
theory are well that you being Wes
well that have any kind of role and and
your perspective in the book well it's
always a a issue that I have to deal
with as a scholar from the West but in
some ways it's always been an issue that
I've dealt with because I actually lived
in Japan for 12 years before coming to
Yale and I was very active writing many
of my articles in Japanese sometimes I
felt that my position was not in Japan
or in America it was somewhere in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean probably
drowning somewhere but that I always had
this kind of ambiguous position and it's
one that I've thought is actually kind
of productive that I can actually use
that position both to provide to provide
an outside perspective a critical as
perspective not only on Japanese cinema
but also on Western theory and you know
it's a good opportunity I think to do
some interesting things because frankly
most scholars in Japan have not thought
about Japanese film theory there's only
one book that's been written about it by
a great film critic named Sato Adele has
a very eclectic book it's basically him
picking a couple people who've written
about cinema but most of the time just
talking about what he wants to talk
about it's still a very interesting book
but it's not really a good history but I
still run into many Japanese who say
what there was film theory in Japan I
mean that's the kind of complex that I'm
dealing with so in fact it's actually
good for me to be a westerner saying
well actually there's actually quite a
lot there and already some of the things
I'm presenting both in Japanese and
English are causing a lot of other
people to start thinking about this so
one of my projects beyond writing this
history is actually to do an anthology
okay
but what's interesting is that we've
decided to do an anthology
both in Japanese and in English because
nothing has actually been produced in
Japan
on that and it'll be myself another
American scholar and a Japanese scholar
who are the three editors so it's very
much an international endeavor and
hopefully it'll be an intervention not
only in Japanese film studies but also
in American or European film studies you
know I was going to ask you how will
your book be unique from the others and
basically you've already answer the
question there are no sadder there been
some great works in Japanese film
history or Japanese film studies which
deal with particular periods or in
particular issues which within that
might take up some of these theorists
about you know this one is really going
to be the first one that tries to deal
with the longer history from supposedly
the beginning towards up to today or
well that's the big problem of writing
this because you know it helps when
other people have done it before because
they can choose or select what's the
important thing to talk about
whereas with no other people writing
about it I've got to do that so it means
you know I've got to go through
literally thousands of articles and try
to figure out well what's important what
are the things that deserve being talked
about in my history where do you start
where do you end who do you include who
do you not include and there's a lot of
politics involved in that which can be
rather nasty and rather complex I will
probably be criticized by lots and lots
of graduate students in the future about
my selections but nonetheless I think
it's very exciting because there's a lot
of new ground to break and kind of feel
like a little bit of a pioneer there you
know and part of what I've decided to do
at least about when to end
it is to probably end around 1980 and
why there one reason being because you
know really one of the great last film
theorists Hassoun me shigeko that's
really when he becomes very popular so I
might end with his work but the other
problem is is that the people who are
writing after that are probably all my
friends okay or colleagues and then you
get into the problem of including and
not including being a very personal
issue I say so I kind of don't want to
step on too many people's toes so I'll
kind of arbitrarily kind of but I think
with some good reasons ended around 1980
okay now does your research involve
actually viewing any films well I mean
that's one of the interesting things
about the Japanese history of film
theory because especially if these
Japanese theorists were thinking about
cinema in fundamental ways but still
working under a kind of oppressive
condition where philosophy or thought or
theory is a Western phenomenon Japanese
are not supposed to be doing it it
sometimes has led Japanese to actually
engage in other forms of theory doing
questions or pursuing questions of what
is cinema in fields not normally
recognised as theory so so for instance
in film criticism usually in the West we
clearly divide film criticism in film
theory but in my case for instance one
interesting thing is that there are
actually many pieces of literature which
are actually very very profound
investigations of film but also I think
you can make an argument there are a
number of films themselves that are
actually very very intriguing
investigations of what is cinema in part
that comes from the fact that some of
the great film theorists in Japan are
actually some of the great film makers
okay I mean you see this in Europe as
well less in America
but you know many filmmakers are
actually quite intellectual and quite
profound in thinking about their own
discipline now you could argue that all
filmmakers in some ways are trying to
think about what you can do in cinema
but especially in Japan and in some
places in Europe some of them actually
wrote that down on paper and so you can
look at those theorists and also at
their films and really try to think
about well what are they really saying
about cinema not simply in their words
but also in their images so you know I'm
not sure how far along you are on the
process with the book but for better or
worse have you come across anything that
have has surprised you or something that
you haven't expected you know I mean
there are a number of things I mean
obviously you come across some brilliant
people one of the great finds I think
has been this fellow named a guy Mitch
stato who is largely forgotten in Japan
he wrote just really one book plus a
number of essays but one book called
form expression and formation or film
expression in formation which is
brilliant it's really one of the best
books I think written on cinema anywhere
Wow and especially in the 1970s 1980s
one of the great French philosophers
Jill de leurs wrote a book on cinema
which especially talked about the issue
of time and cinema he is one of the
representatives of a trend we call film
philosophy which is sometimes
distinguished from film theory that is
using cinema to answer fundamental
questions about philosophy okay like
what is time but now a guy meets cello
in 1940 is basically talking about what
Deleuze is talking about forty years
before I mean obviously in a different
way but still in a really really
fascinating way so there are these finds
about you know really really interesting
people but also I think you know there
are trends throughout Japanese film
theory which I think are very
fascinating
for instance in American or European
especially British film studies it was
from the 1970s that people really
started thinking about spectatorship how
spectators the people who watch films
are actually very very important in the
process of film production that they in
fact are part of the process of creating
the meaning of films but what's the
interesting is that in Japanese film
history especially this history of film
theory
you see people talking about that from
1914 because that's in fact one of the
main points of Gandia snowscape it's he
actually doesn't talk about individual
films he doesn't talk about directors
because to him it doesn't matter
it's the spectators who make films and
to him that is the reason why cinema is
modern because it is the sign in fact
the representative of the arrival of the
modern masses that they are going to be
taking over culture because it is
through their cinema viewing that
they're creating culture which thing you
cannot do with literature you cannot do
with theatre so cinema to him is the
marker of a new civilization and
precisely centered around the activity
of the spectator and that becomes I
think a trend you see that in other
theorists in the 20s 30s 40s into the
post-war who are very interested in this
issue of spectatorship which has not
been a major issue in Western film
theory necessarily in the same way up
until you know the 1970s well it sounds
like a fascinating project I wish you
all the best and thank you so much for
being here with us and sharing some of
your work well thank you for inviting me
again for more information about
Professor Jareau and his research please
visit our website at yale.edu slash
macmillan report be sure to join us for
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale